what's up youtubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about data so I talked in my last
video about statistics being one of the
real core sets of skills that you need
to have in order to be successful in
data science but I also understand
there's a lot of you who want to go into
data science who are maybe going through
school right now maybe you have an
applied stats major or minor or you're
not even necessarily in stats in the
first place for instance a lot of people
go into data science from a computer
science or from an engineering
background so I want to talk to you guys
today about how much statistics you
really need to know and what the most
important things are to know to maximize
your chances of number one getting a
data science job in the first place but
then number two once you had that job
actually being effective at it so before
we get into this just a little bit about
me so I actually have a master's degree
and applied statistics myself now if
you're asking me do I use my degree
every single day in my job my answer
would be yes but sort of the reason I
say that is necessarily when you get a
degree in statistics or in a lot of
different other fields for that matter
they're really gonna hone your critical
thinking and your inferential reasoning
skills because you're constantly solving
problems that are unclear that you
really have to think through and you're
really flexing those muscles in your
brain that are responsible for solving
complex problems so education is very
helpful as far as the actual skills that
I learned during the degree I would say
there are some on the heavy theoretical
side which I've never once used and
there's other skills which I use almost
every single day so just as a bit of a
disclaimer I've worked in data science
for about five years now and what I'm
about to discuss as what I feel are the
most important things to know in
statistics are based on my own personal
experience they're also based on the
anecdotal experiences of colleagues and
people in my network that I keep in
contact with as well as research that
I've done
in that sense take these with a little
bit of a grain of salt because your
experience could certainly vary and it
definitely varies across regional lines
as well but having said that I really do
believe if you know these things you're
going to be in a really good position in
the data science world
all right so speaking broadly about
statistics as it pertains to data
science you need to have good solid
scientific foundation behind the work
that you do you also need to have tools
in your arsenal for attacking various
problems and then you need to be able to
explain your work and understand the
things which influence the world that
you're doing data science work on so
I've grouped the things that you need to
know in statistics into three different
categories number one I've got the
foundation type stuff
I've got tools and I've got reasoning
inferential type skill sets so if we
start with the foundational skills
number one I've got here is probability
so knowing probability is really gonna
give some integrity behind your work and
the reason for that is all of statistics
at the end of the day is based on
probability theory so I would understand
things like doing probability
calculations the central limit theorem
conditional probability Bayes rule these
are things which have wide reaching
implications to a variety of different
subject spaces so understanding those
things is gonna go a really long way
next down the list I have distributions
so I would understand things like the
expected value of a distribution or of a
random variable rather the variance also
things like just generating and working
with that distribution inside of a
programming language so calculating
quantiles
using them to perform probability
calculations things like those you don't
have to necessarily know every single
distribution but some key ones like the
normal exponential maybe gamma and beta
uniform those are things which you
should probably have in your toolbox so
for the next item on the list we have
estimation now often in data science
you're going
to be asked to estimate some sort of
quantity but it's not going to be enough
to provide just a point estimate for it
you're going to need to provide some
kind of interval in order to communicate
what the spread or the uncertainty
around that quantity is and so when we
think about something like a confidence
interval specifically it could be any
confidence level 90% 95% 99% whatever
have you you need to be able to generate
that confidence interval inside of a
programming language and then interpret
it so that say it's a 95% confidence
level what does that mean and then that
interval that you created in the first
place what exactly does that mean and
now for the final item under foundation
I've got inference now that to me is
understanding the hypothesis testing
framework from beginning to end and now
in your data science job it's extremely
unlikely that you're gonna spend all of
your day conducting a bunch of t-tests
or a bunch of small-scale hypothesis
tests that's really not going to happen
but that's also not really the point
because the hypothesis testing framework
starting from stating what you're trying
to test then working with a p-value
that's getting generated from your data
and then coming up with the conclusion
that's a really helpful framework for
thinking through what you can
demonstrate and what you can't
demonstrate through statistics and
through data science so speaking about
p-values I would thoroughly understand
what that number indicates and then more
honestly more importantly what it
doesn't mean and then also as far as
hypothesis testing is concerned multiple
comparisons rear their ugly head and
data science all the time so
understanding how to tackle those
problems and then things like multiple
comparisons for instance a bonferroni
correction as an example those are
things which you should probably be
equipped to work with as well and now
next up we have the tools which you're
actually going to use to attack problems
so for a lot of instances
linear models will actually be enough
suppose it's some kind of classification
or regression problem where you're
trying to classify or predict some kind
of outcome for a lot of those problems a
linear or logistic regression type of
approach will suffice and the biggest
reason for that is because a lot of
people in all kinds of industries even
if they don't come from mathematical or
statistical backgrounds they intuitively
understand the concepts and the meaning
behind the linear models the reason for
that is because these things can be
explained by pretty straightforward
mathematics they're not black boxy type
approaches the way a lot of machine
learning models are and being able to
interpret and understand why the model
is returning the results that it is
that's going to be very important for a
large number of stakeholders so I would
understand how to create these models
how to work with things like some basic
model selection backwards and forward
selection and then also you're going to
create a model inside of your
programming language and it's going to
return a lot of output you need to be
able to understand all of that output so
wrapped inside of that output you have
things we discussed under the
fundamentals things like a confidence
interval for your slope parameters
you're conducting a hypothesis test in
the background so just understanding how
all those things tie together that's
something that you're gonna want to know
and next up everybody's favorite machine
learning or at least that's some
people's favorites some people hate it
some people love it I happen to love it
now machine learning is gonna vary
substantially depending on the job that
you're working in some jobs may have you
working in machine learning everyday
some not at all and that's really going
to depend a lot on how advanced that
company's infrastructure and data
science processes are but having some of
those tools in your arsenal is going to
be helpful particularly with supervised
learning or classification or regression
problems because it's pretty well known
a lot of machine learning algorithms
generally are going to outperform more
linear type models now
you don't need to be familiar with every
single model in the book but these days
things like decision trees and random
forests those terms get tossed around a
lot so those are things you should
familiarize yourself with some what
things like K nearest neighbors support
vector machines neural networks those
are some of the other really big
algorithms out there these days
so certainly be able to implement them
inside of a programming language now
these days things like scikit-learn in
python or carrot and AR that makes the
whole streamlined process super easy so
I would be able to work with that entire
process now I must say as a caveat it's
really easy to get good at the actual
programming of a machine learning model
but something that's really going to set
you apart is knowing how you could
actually improve that model so to me
that often comes back to understanding
the bias and variance trade-off
oftentimes with a lot of different data
sets you're going to run into an
overfitting problem now being able to
think through how to address that and
make your model perform better that is
really gonna set you apart from a lot of
other people lastly under tools I've
included survival analysis and my reason
for that one is partly personal that's
because I've worked in the healthcare
and the pharmaceutical space a lot so
survival analysis comes up all the time
so things like working with a
kaplan-meier curve working with a Cox
proportional hazards model basically
anything involving some kind of time to
event outcome or time to event endpoint
that could come up in a lot of different
industries not just in the two that I
describe so that's probably going to be
a good one to know as well moving on to
our third and final category we have
reasoning or what I like to call
elements in the statistical world which
can help to which can help you to
interpret as well as explain the space
behind your analysis the design
shortcomings and things like that
so if we start with the first bullet
item we've got assumptions so any single
statistical model or test that you do is
going to carry with it some level of
conditions or assumptions now you don't
want to just blindly throw a test or a
model a problem you need to know these
conditions and assumptions so that you
can be sure that your test or model is
appropriate now to take that just a
little bit of a step further there are
some conditions which are going to be
important sometimes and sometimes the
results of your analysis are going to be
robust even if that condition isn't
necessarily met so just as an example
suppose you're working with a two-sample
t-tests and you have two groups a sample
of a hundred under each group now one of
the conditions of that test is normality
the problem is once you have a large
enough sample size you could actually
simulate this and figure out that most
of the time even if you don't have
normality in your two groups because you
had that large sample size you're not
gonna have any real problem from a type
1 error or from a power standpoint so
you can probably go ahead with that test
without any problems even though you're
violating that assumption however things
like independence of your actual data
points now if you violate that you're in
a world of problems so understanding
some of these things is something that's
going to serve you pretty well next up
on the list we have bias now there are
all kinds of different biases which can
affect your analysis now there are all
different kinds of biases
there's response bias there selection
bias there survivorship bias there's
more than I can even list off the top of
my head so I would get familiar with
these because they will show up in your
work and you need to understand how it
could affect your results and then
lastly we have confounding so this is
the general idea that shows up in causal
or general inferential problems where X
is thought to influence Y but really
there's some
ground variable Z that's affecting both
x and y so if you don't know it
definitely look up Simpsons paradox
understand that concept inward and
outward because that's something that's
going to show up all the time and
knowing that is really gonna set you
apart as a data scientist and as a
consultant so to understand some of
these reasoning concepts a little bit
better I really do recommend a book
called how not to be wrong it's by
Jordan elenberg it's really good at Dell
diving really deep into some of these
reasoning ideas so it definitely talks
about bias it talks about confounding it
talks about a whole variety of other
principles and it really brings a
mathematical and a statistical edge to
them for the non mathematician and the
non statistician link will be in the
description so in conclusion as I'm sure
you all know the data science field
varies very substantially from job to
job so as a result the skill sets that
are going to be required are going to
vary substantially as well so that is
the challenge with lists like these as a
result the more knowledge that you have
the better having said that obviously
data science is an industry where the
demand for knowledge is quite high so
for that average person who wants to get
into data science do really well in
their job and isn't necessarily
interested in developing the field in
either the Silicon Valley world or
publishing research I really do believe
that these skills if you master them and
get good at them they're going to serve
you incredibly well so thanks again for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
smash the like button and hit the
subscribe button if you agree or
disagree with the content then please
leave a comment down below and let me
know and then I will see you in the not
so distant future until then Richard on
data